- [Devin] The criminal
justice system is filled
with arcane legal terminology.
Lay people often use this
vernacular incorrectly.
- Habeas Corpus.
- [Devin] They say bad law words.
- Incredibly exact.
- [Devin] But we can make
these bad law words good?
What actually is a chicken?
There's a whole debate over
whether a hot dog is a sandwich.
That's generally how lay people sound
when they're using legal concepts.
That defines a tomato as a fruit,
even though we all know
a tomato is a vegetable.
Malice aforethought,
Good Samaritan law,
an offense against all the people.
Right off the bat is begging the question.
A catch 22.
The Bed of Procrustes.
Imminent and eminent.
Insure versus ensure.
And then there's forego versus forgo.
Because I'm informed
that some of you actually
are not lawyers and that saddens me
so welcome to Bad Law Words Good.
Legal Eagle.